and trevor williams making his final
start of the year
strikeout to start now anthony rizzo
shortens up with two strikes
and he drives that one out into deep
right center
[Music]
an 0-2 pitch
choking up on the bat and that's number
11.
wow
don't get fooled put it in play hit a
line drive the other way all that good
stuff with two strikes but if you make a
mistake whether he's choked up or not he
still has the ability to hit it a long
way kyle hendricks will make his final
start of the regular season
frasier 444 lifetime against him
and that one sent down the line adam
frazier
leads off the game with a home run
ninth time in his career adam frazier
has gone deep to start things
how about that for an answer
and uh boy yeah he got a hold of that
fastball um one in there and adam
frazier i guess uh contreras wanted a
little higher than that left it thigh
high and frazier knew that right away i
was looking forward to this matchup too
uh key brian hayes
he squared that up nicely
about three home runs in a row
starlings last night and frazier and
hayes go deep against hendricks
well he got a good one to hit rock and
he didn't miss it he is just again he
makes adjustments he does things it's
pretty impressive making dad proud
obviously another two strike homer
another two strike hit
i mean he has been incredible with two
strikes
i believe that's his 13th hit
hitting close to 300 with two strikes
gets the fastball
oliver the batter two to one pirates
here's a line drive center field coming
in half makes a sliding backhand catch
good play ian happ and that will end the
end second walk for trevor williams and
now ian happ
hard hit it finds williams
who gets the out at first i'm not sure
exactly where it got him but uh you'd
never know he just got hit with the ball
and that ball wasn't
hit softly i mean that ball was hit
pretty good i think he turned around and
got him in the back side
which
if you're trying to pick apart
good idea yeah
that's not a bad place to get
hit they're gonna come check him out
back to work
for that one four to three one down
and the batter cameron maben they even
pulls the ground ball fair down the left
field line past a diving haze it's going
to be a two base hit from maben the
throw to second base cameron slides in
safely
he's got a double walk number three two
aboard for javier baez
these wild swings the 0-1 bouncing ball
toward hayes he'll throw to second for
one and on to first and a little
hesitation by frazier
and a safe call at first base
maven safe at third they get the
middleman hayward at second on the 5-4
fielder's choice
baez takes over at first but now there
are two down jason kipnis is at the
plate he popped up to keep ryan hayes in
the second inning
and did he go a pitch in the dirt yes
according to the third base umpire on
the appeal and jason kipnis really
surprised and angry at that call from
bill welke
the 2-2 pitch is a roller left side
sliding stop by keep brian hayes gets to
his feet throws to first and retires
wilson contreras here's a guy you want
to come to watch every night three
three full strides and a dive
up quickly
strong and accurate throw you know
gonzales i'm not sure eric gonzalez he's
gonna get there but he's gonna have to
throw it on the run moving away from
first base yeah he covers a lot of
ground to keep brian hayes two down
nobody on two to one pirates sixth
inning cameron maben
that's a fair ball for maven that'll
kick off that diagonal wall
and cameron maven is two for three both
hits or doubles
two men on now the potential go ahead
run on at first so baez will face the
left-hander austin davis davis not even
looking at him so mabin just takes off
and he steals third without a throw
stallings didn't even look at third he
knew he had no chance to get maben
so now any kind of a wild pitch or a
pass ball and maybe
mabin will score the tying run
the pitch
fly ball to center field hit deep going
back is oliva to the track he makes the
catch
and austin davis gets the final out by
getting baez to hit a fly ball to deep
center field with four hits pretty quiet
since this first inning for hendricks
since uh hayes homeward he's allowed two
base runners both two out singles moran
a sharp single his last time up
hit it
wow
was in the outfield grass
still lined it right over his head
and moran
really benefiting from the day off he's
two out of three polanco walks jose
osuna the batter
ground ball left side shortstop by us
has it go to kipnus one over to rizzo
double play
a double play ends the inning now hayes
who homer to center
look at this he's got another hit
another one
crazy's gonna turn the bag
hayward's got a good arm and it's late
frazier in at third on the base hit by
key brian hayes
all right the cubs want to challenge
whether frazier comes off the bag
well is that toe on the side of the base
at the time of the tag yeah that's his
only hope as if his right
foot the right toe
as he's coming up does the right toe
get to the bag
before the tag
that's the new play you have to finish
it out because little challenges like
this with video replay now you can get
guys
here's the verdict
[Music]
so that is huge i'll say two ounce
runner at first
that will be it for hendricks who was
terrific after the two homers he has
kept the pirates off the board a wild
pitch a man in scoring position with two
outs
ian half
he struck him out
richard rodriguez
pins down the save and the pirates ride
home runs from fraser and hayes all the
way to the finish line thanks to some
good pirate pitching tonight